hi my name is Alex Marshall I am an
assistant professor at North Carolina
Central University and today I'm gonna
talk a little bit about the reciprocal
relationship between cybercrime
dysregulation and binge alcohol
consumption and so just as a brief
overview of what i'm gonna go over it'll
be a little bit of background about
alcohol abuse and dependence and then
i'll talk a little bit about neuro
inflammation versus neuron immune
responses so you'll see a lot of times
where i'll compare two different aspects
of either alcohol abuse versus
dependence or neuron formation versus no
immune responses and then just go
through a few results where i looked at
a couple of cytokines and glial cells
and then end with some conclusions i
like to call them the take home message
so i'm all abuse or alcoholism
alcoholism as most people typically call
it is a huge problem in the United
States approximately 10% of the
population suffers from alcohol abuse or
will be classified as having an alcohol
use disorder but over 60% of individuals
actually consume alcohol and some form
or fashion
more than 50 percent of Americans
because of this because of the
epidemiology around it have a close
relative who has or has had a problem
with alcohol abuse estimates suggest
that it cost the United States
approximately two hundred twenty four
billion dollars to correct issues
associated with alcohol abuse and that
includes things like missing work
property damage to car accidents as well
as health care from hospital visits the
majority the vast majority of these
expenses are associated with binge
drinking and I'll defined what binge
drinking is a little bit later in this
presentation you should know that one in
six US adults in the United States binge
drink more than four times a month and
again I'll just find what then shrinking
is a little bit later and but what my
lab is interested in or what I'm
interested in is what happens as someone
goes from
experimenting with alcohol so maybe
someone's a social drinker and
occasionally they might have a glass or
two to when they start to abuse alcohol
and so when we talk about abuse we're
talking about alcohol under problematic
situation so whether it is binge
drinking or drinking during periods that
are inappropriate so if your underage
drinking that would be considered abuse
individuals who are pregnant and
drinking that would also be classified
as alcohol abuse but binge drinking
itself is characterized as drinking four
to five drinks within a two-hour period
and it results in a B C above or a
blood-alcohol concentration above eighty
milligrams per deciliter and so we'll
focus in on binge drinking as a
particular part of abuse but my lab is
actually interested in what occurs
during binge drinking compared to what
happens when someone becomes addicted so
there is a progression that happens
there's changes in the brain and there
are changes in the peripheral system
that promote alcohol consumption over
time and lead to dependence or addiction
so while most people may not think about
alcohol abuse as being a
neurodegenerative disorder and people
who suffer from alcoholism and are
chronic consumers of high levels of
alcohol do have damage to the CNS that's
just as debilitating or damaging as
individuals with Alzheimer's disease and
so you can see on the red line a group
of people who their MRI was checked or
their brain was checked with an MRI and
you can see that it is just as damaging
alcohol is just as damaging as
Alzheimer's disease in certain regions
on the right there is a social drinker
versus an alcoholic you can see that
there are changes in the ventricle sizes
so there's an increase in the ventricles
as well as a general loss brain matter
and so my interest in the neuro immune
system originally started because of
changes
associated with damage so when you think
about the newer immune system people
often consider how norm flame which are
responses lead to neuro degeneration and
so this is true and multiple sclerosis
is true and Alzheimer's disease and so
what people have found or what clinical
studies have shown is that alcoholics
actually do have symptoms or signs of
having some kind of neuron mewn response
and so on the right it says I be a one
and I be a one is a marker for microglia
and so at the top there is a control
[Music]
more social drinker versus at the bottom
someone post more time who as an
alcoholic and you can see that there a
drastic changes and the microglial sites
to the right it's showing both mzp-1
chemokine associated with an ER immune
response as well as changes in receptors
so toll-like receptors and you can see
that for comparing the controls versus
now an alcoholic there's a drastic
increase in the concentration of either
chemokines associated with the neuro
immune response or the receptors
associated with an immune response and
so this all came out of the Fulton
Cruz's lab down at UNC and so this is
kind of how I originally got into
studying the neuro-immune system in
terms of what happens up with alcohol
abuse and so the reason for that is
because when people again think about
the neuro immune response they think
about it in terms of being either a
protective mechanism kind of fighting
against pathogens or damage to the
system or housekeepers so kind of
getting rid of cellular debris i'm from
the damage and so the neuro immune
response or its consists of glial
activation so markedly and astrocytes
and the neuro immune response includes
the or the neuro main system includes
the blood-brain barrier so a neuro
inflammatory response would include
disruption of the blood-brain barrier
and a neuro inflammatory response would
include in frustration or
lymphocytes and neutrophils and so again
at the top on the right I'm showing some
of the damage associated with chronic
alcohol abuse
and so one of the theories behind that
is that you have damage to both the CNS
and the peripheral system that causes
glial activation disruption of the
blood-brain barrier and then
infiltration of peripheral immune
signaling and so this particular graph
at the bottom is from an Alzheimer's
paper but it's showing how peripheral
immune responses can influence the neuro
immune system and cause degradation and
so that's one of the theories behind
[Music]
alcohol use disorders and neural
degeneration but as I got into the nerve
I mean system and really got interested
in what was going on I started learning
more and more about this field called
psychoneuroimmunology and so in
psychoneuroimmunology the interest is
more about how the immune system affects
behavior or how it affects
[Music]
neurotransmission and so this particular
diagram on the right is from a paper on
pain but what's important about it is
that you can see that their cytokines
that are secreted by activated glial
cells so again we have microglia and
astrocytes that are secreting these
cytokines but when they secrete these
cytokines not only can they cause an
immune response that would be associated
with neuro degeneration but importantly
you can see that the neurons themselves
have receptors that can respond to these
cytokines to cytokine signaling
particularly what interested me is some
of the pro-inflammatory cytokines
actually map on to the pharmacology of
alcoholism or alcohol abuse so um where
where you can see Iowan beta and il-6
actually inhibit gaba and inhibit gaba
and can increase the glutamatergic tone
that's the that actually Maps on to what
alcohol Jess so alcohol
is a GABA agonist that can also be an
antagonist at the NMDA receptors and so
what really interested me is if we are
seeing changes in the nerman response
and alcohol dependence when does that
happen
does it happen before someone becomes
dependent and if it happens
does it affect behavior long before FX
degeneration and so again one of the
first questions that I wanted to look at
was what happens to the neuro immune
system and the transitionary period and
then alcohol use development so what
happens when someone is binge drinking
so I don't know this guy I'm gonna call
him Sean but Sean is the epitome of
binge drinking remember I said that it
is drinking four to five drinks and a
two hour period and he is going well
above that and having what looks like
five beers and I'm assuming under two
minutes and so the way that I study that
is by using a paradigm known as the
drinking in the dark model and then this
model we give mice access to alcohol for
four days straight three hours into the
dark cycle they are giving us access for
two to four hours depending on the
paradigm but importantly when they have
access to this alcohol they consume it
themselves they achieve blood ethanol
concentrations that map onto binge
drinking so they achieve blood ethanol
concentrations around 80 to 120
milligrams per deciliter and they start
to actually exhibit behavior
intoxication similar to that which you
would see in a human so they have motor
deficits and they actually consume this
alcohol for the pleasure of consuming
alcohol as opposed for the caloric need
associated with with with alcohol itself
the other important part about this
model is that these mice that drink in
this period are not dependent and they
don't show evidence in neuro
degeneration so we can look to see
what's happening to the neuro immune
system way before someone you know
anthropomorphizing way before someone is
actually dependent on alcoholism or on
alcohol
and so the first thing that we do is
characterize what's going on to the no
immune response and so we do that by
using PCR and you notice the chemistry
analyzes and so you'll see in the
experiments that the it's set up so that
they either got alcohol once or three
times depending on the paradigm or they
got alcohol and then we waited to see
what occurred in accidents so in the PCR
experiment they got alcohol over the
four days and we gave them zero to seven
days of abstinence to understand what
was occurring in the system or they got
alcohol one or three times and again
depending on the experiment we're
euthanized at different periods to
understand the persisting nature of
those Neronian changes so when the first
ones are first cytokines that we looked
at was interleukin-1 beta Iowan beta is
a pro-inflammatory cytokine so one of
the first things that we saw using
immunity chemistry was that there's an
increase in Iowan beta in the
basolateral medulla and so this this the
slide shows and on the left animals they
got water or ethanol and on the right
the animals either got water or sucrose
the top half is looking at the basal
lateral amygdala and the bottom half is
looking at the central amygdala and so
what we found was that specifically in
the BL a there was an increase in IO and
beta after three cycles of abuse this
did not occur when the animals only had
access to sucrose and again it did not
occur in the central amygdala when we
look to see how long it persist because
of the methodology this is the entire
amygdala as opposed to basal lateral
versus central but what we found is that
using PCR ethanol exposure actually
causes increases and IO and beta mRNA
expression that persists even 7 days
after abstinence so where it says zero
that is immediately following ethanol
exposure as opposed to seven days out we
still see that increase in IOM beta
looking at an anti-inflammatory cytokine
ten or interleukin-10 in the amygdala we
actually found the opposite reaction so
as the animals had more access to
alcohol they had a greater depression in
Aisle 10 and so again this particular
graph is using Eliza's and so what's
important to point out here is that it
only occurs in the CNS and not in the
peripheral system so at the top we are
looking at graphs of aisle 10
specifically in the amygdala again it's
the entire angela not VLA versus CDA and
but you can see that after three weeks
you see a decrease in aisle 10 and
following ethanol exposure this did not
occur with sucrose but importantly when
we looked in the peripheral system and
used serum and there were no differences
and il-10 between the animals that had
ethanol or water and so that kind of
characterizes what happens in the to the
new immune system from my apologies so
we had this pro-inflammatory milieu that
occurs following ethanol exposure but
what I really want to understand is how
what's the relationship in the opposite
direction so how does this newer immune
response affect alcohol abuse and some
of the decision making of the mice in
order to consume alcohol and so
previously there's been some studies
from the Harris lab out in Texas showing
that peripheral immune modulators
actually affect ethanol consumption and
so they use PD for inhibitors and saw
that it reduced ethanol consumption but
what I wanted to do was to manipulate
specifically the nura mewn response so
without changing peripheral immune
responses if we can narrow in on the
neuro immune response and see if it
actually affects consumption in order to
do that we use stereotactic surgery and
use guide cannulas directly into a
specific brain regions and so this
diagram is showing the cannula going
into the central
but if you move it more laterally than
you would be in the basal lateral
amygdala so we gave the animals access
to alcohol to establish a baseline
consumption they underwent surgery and
then in a Latin square design they
either got the society kind of interest
or placebo or vehicle rather directly
into these brain regions to see how it
under affected ethanol consumption and
so because we first saw the change in
Iowan beta we originally started with
Iowan receptor antagonists and so the
Iowan receptor antagonists directly into
the basal lateral amygdala actually
reduced ethanol consumption and so you
can see in the bar on the left that's
our Saline control and on the right
those animals received IO and receptor
antagonist directly into the basal
lateral amygdala importantly this
actually reduced ethanol consumption i'm
sorry not ethanol consumption reduced
blood F in all concentrations and so the
animals fall well below what is defined
as a a binge level Dec so remember the
binge level BC is anything above eighty
milligrams per deciliter that's where
you start to have a lot of motor
deficits and the more classical
intoxication parameters that are
problematic in terms of driving and/or
interacting with individuals and so
we're getting B C's that fall more into
the social drinking level it did not
affect sucrose consumption and so when
you give when you test these kinds of
paradigms you also want to make sure
that it is not a reducing general reward
and so one of the ways to do that is to
use sucrose as a another rewarding
solution outside of alcohol so while it
reduce alcohol consumption it had no
effect on sucrose when we did the same
thing in the central amygdala where
there are no changes in Iowan beta we
did not see any changes in ethanol
consumption or the blood ethanol
situations likewise when we use another
anti-inflammatory interleukin 10 we saw
that Isleton reduces ethanol consumption
in the VLA that reduction and ethanol
consumption also resulted in the
decrease in PVCs again there was no
change when we gave sucrose and no
differences when we looked at giving you
in the central amygdala and so so far
what we've been able to manipulate is
really in the amygdala but recently we
had a paper come out that shows that
this dysregulation the neuro-immune
response is not isolated to the amygdala
in terms of non dependent binge alcohol
consumption and so we've gone back and
we looked at the hippocampus and we see
a similar story there so we see that
binge alcohol exposure actually
increases IO and beta and hippocampus
and decreases il-10 and then we also
looked at specifically some glial
changes so looking at astrocytes which
is actually our even published so we see
an increase in national site activation
following multiple binge exposures and
the hippocampus as well as we've
recently done some work looking at
marker bleeeh
but that's not published yet and so
overall our take-home message or the
take-home message for this presentation
is that excessive alcohol consumption
induces inner immune responses those
inner immune responses feedback and
affect both biology and behavior so
specifically today I only talked about
behavioral paradigms but we've also done
things where we've manipulated the neuro
immune response to see whether and
correct for or decreases in your
degeneration and so our hope is that
therapies targeting the neuro mean
response may reduce drinking and therein
induce reduce the damage associated with
excessive alcohol consumption with that
being said I'd like to thank my mentors
my previous mentors from my postdoctoral
experience at you and
as well as my graduate mentor UK the
majority of the work that I showed today
was actually done by some undergraduates
at High Point University by Drew Evans
even Green Grove and Bill of graphic and
I'm still building the lab actually just
started essential about six weeks ago
now and so I currently have a few
undergrads who or who are signed on to
work in the lab none of this would be
possible without support financial
support and so some of this was
supported by ni triple a through of 54
and we recently got an award from the
Alzheimer's Association that has also
helped to further these these projects